los demócratas argumentan que donald
trump incitó no solamente el 6 de enero
a que sus simpatizantes se tomaran el
capitolio y generarán pues este impasse
que vive la democracia estadounidense
los republicanos dice que la palabra las
palabras de trump ese día no incitaron a
que milicias simpatizantes a donald
trump hayan cometido esos actos
violencia violentos cuatro horas
entonces durará este debate se hará la
votación y alrededor de las cinco de la
tarde se conocerá si el caso es
constitucional para sí entonces el líder
demócrata james skin mañana presente
pues los argumentos demócratas tendrán
16 horas
el líder demócrata que posiblemente se
divida en máximo dos días y 16 horas
también tendrán los abogados de donald
trump para presentar los argumentos a
favor de el ex presidente para que pues
no sea llevado por este segundo juicio
político después entonces será patrick
leahy que estará presidiendo este
proceso el demócrata el senador más
viejo
en el senado el que haga preguntas y
haga intervenciones a partir de los
comentarios y las preguntas que reciba
tanto de demócratas como republicanos a
los abogados de donald trump oa los
mismos representantes demócratas de la
cámara de representantes que están
acusando al presidente trampa entonces
después de esas cuatro horas que tendrá
práctica ley y para cuestionar a las dos
partes vendrá entonces lo que todavía
está en juego todavía no se ha definido
y es si se cita o no a testigos es lo
que ni demócratas ni republicanos pues
han definido todavía y es que pues
muchos dicen que demócratas tienen
vídeos suficientes pruebas suficientes y
no van a tener que acudir a testigos y
eso va a hacer que el juicio entonces
sea mucho menos demorado de los 21 días
que demoró el primer juicio contra
donald trump después de citar a testigos
es cuando viene la votación vienen las
intervenciones finales y se hace la
votación o no
donald trump pues es declarado culpable
en este segundo impeachment para como
dicen los demócratas poder así entonces
votar nuevamente a ver si donald trump
pues se le prohíbe volver a aspirar a un
cargo público